we were actually running into the issues
of wow this hiring is time consuming
it's kind of scary at at first and the
tools out there were just not sufficient
you know a lot of tools were a bit
clunky or very expensive for a bootstrap
company
so it really started out of our own
frustration of you know how do you
organize such a hiring process
and how do you collaborate because paul
was we always had working i've been
working remote
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with ctec
recruiting is becoming
more and more relevant in a bigger and
bigger challenge as the world moves to
digital
and not all businesses adapt so quickly
to the recruiting habits that
tech giants have adopted well today
we're joined by perry ustmann
meet perry usdam co-founder of
recruiting
perry is the ceo and co-founder of
recruiti a global talent acquisition and
candidate experience platform
with a passion for tech and scaling
teams he has been active in the sas
space as a founder
advisor and investor perry believes in
the power of hr tech to help
revolutionize the way companies and
teams grow
perry joshdam thank you for joining me
all the way from the netherlands how are
you
good thank you michael thanks for having
me
i'm always so excited when i have people
all around the world joining me talking
about their passions their experiences
today we're going to talk about talent
acquisition and hiring and why
you know it's a difficult painful
process sometimes but why recruiting
helps make it easier i believe with more
than 4 000 customers already so i'm
excited to hear about
the the story of recruti but but even
before that
i i have to talk about your passion with
golf and
the analogy to entrepreneurship so perry
who are you and how does golf play a
part in in your cool life
thanks yeah sure happy to talk a bit
about golf too
um i guess it started as a bit of a joke
to be honest like
about eight or nine years ago i saw my
dad's golf clubs in the basement and i
actually
i took them i cleaned them up and i went
to my dad i said hey i think it's time
you and i play some golf
he said now man they're rusty they're
old i said no they're here they're clean
let's go
it started off as a bit of a joke in the
weekends my brother joined
and somehow we got into the habit of
playing golf every saturday it's still
routine you can actually put your alarm
every saturday at one i'm at the golf
course together with my dad and brother
just a fun afternoon um it it's kind of
like these things that once you get the
hang of it and you become passionate you
could there's a very fine line between
you know being obsessed and and having a
hobby right that's kind of like
extreme here so there was a moment i
became quite obsessed with golf and i
just wanted to get better better better
uh quite a commitment so we'll get to
those things later you know in terms of
personality stuff but i see a lot of
similarities between you know golf and
having to commit to become better
especially you know if you want to
become a good student level of course
and entrepreneurship where you have to
you know keep on going and don't stop so
that was the
thing that triggered me yeah now one of
the things that you mentioned earlier is
something about you know the the
resilience
the the calmness how does that play a
part
you know in your life with
entrepreneurship right like the thing i
mean this is again with
with golf as well like you're kind of
your own enemy you know depending on
what level of ambition you have right
you could just be a last entrepreneur
have some fun along the go or you could
be extremely committed and just don't
stop until you reach your goals so
i think we've been the type of person
that just you know we
we kind of have an ambition of saying
okay it's not just just
about helping a couple customers we want
to help as many companies as possible
around the world
and once we saw the attraction in the
early days and we saw like wow our tool
really helps companies you know
find the best people hire as soon as
possible i guess that's the core of what
we're doing
we figured that well now we're on a good
wave there's a good trend there's a lot
of momentum on hiring is
becoming more collaborative companies
realizing how important is to hire good
people
and how difficult it could be of course
so that for us was like okay let's put
our ambition on on becoming you know
number one worldwide in the mid market
segment
wow and so take me now you know in a
different route
in more of tauntic position and hiring
and and
you know your entrance to this ecosystem
with those lenses what first you know
from the netherlands
what do you observe how do you even
begin thinking about the problem of
talent acquisition and hiring that
that's a good question oh honestly it's
a simple answer we actually struggled
ourselves
we had a i co-founded recruiting
together with paul smoksack
we started a different company in 2012
which was a mobile gaming company
a lot of fun we were doing gps games for
for companies
and at some point we were actually
hiring it's a boot was a bootstrap
company so it's just like one
two hires but at some point it was like
a full-time job and that's intense and
to be honest quite difficult we're
hiring for the first time as
a first-time founder so we were actually
running into the issues of wow this
hiring is time consuming
it's kind of scary at at first and the
tools out there were just not sufficient
you know a lot of tools were a bit
clunky or very expensive for a bootstrap
company
so it really started out of our own
frustration of you know how do you
organize such a hiring process
and how do you collaborate because paul
was we always had working uh
been working remote so it it kind of
like
we started to build the tool we would
use ourselves and then we still are
using ourselves of course
right and so what how did you categorize
you know the things you're seeing these
problems you know across the board more
tangibly so
you know we're looking at a lot of
recruiters we're looking at a lot of
people that interview that that need to
hire
what what is sort of like the more
tangible things that they're struggling
with that then
you go and solve with recruiting it's
actually three things like uh it's not
on the side anymore because people kind
of pivot into a new direction but we
always used to say
attract automate predict these three
things like some companies depending on
the size and the type of company you are
of course
either you struggle getting applicants
in the first place right you need help
attracting the right talent could be
employer branding could be job
advertisement could be sourcing on the
web etc depending on
kind of like your inbound strategy
automate the second pillar would be
you have a lot of applicants but how you
get to the work how do you get
automation in your pipeline how do you
standardize emails calendar invites
really about how do you save time
and then thirdly predicting and that's
the interesting part of course when you
look from a technology perspective how
do you predict
which channels to promote your job you
know where do you get most return on
investment in terms of advertisements
whether the best candidates come from
who were first the best candidates in
your team for instance
so it's really about you know attracting
automating your work and predicting
success i think this
depending on the type of company or can
help you most
so this concept of of return on
investment
in in the context of hiring and
recruiting talk to me a little bit more
about that because i don't think that
it's it's trivial
it's a trivial concept to somebody like
me who's not
currently involved actively and in
hiring and seeing the
the cost-benefit analysis sure yeah and
we always say like there's
in terms of talent acquisition platform
i think that's the more technical term
but we call ourselves
there are three ways to get applicants
in right you could either
spend money on dope advertisement you
could source you know yourself like a
sniper bros i guess
and uh referrals like ask your team to
help out
and and it's really that's what we
wanted to cover with recruiting as well
and in terms of return on investment
we literally look you know we have data
from the last 15 years of job
advertisements think about
hundreds of thousands of jobs in various
countries and we literally
just reuse that data to know like if
you're looking for a sales engineer in
amsterdam
we have a pretty good idea on which
channels would give the best return in
terms of visitors
clicks on your ads and actually
applicants so you can even
estimate the cost per higher this way
yeah
wow and so when you're talking about the
automation
part of it talk to me a little bit about
that yeah well that that's the most
interesting part i think and that's of
course the essence of why
we wanted to build something like this
this was a wrong frustration too like
if you think about a recruitment process
there's tons of things involved you know
think about the amount of emails going
back and forth with candidates you wanna
if you need to reject someone you wanna
be polite and send an email i think
about seventy percent of companies not
even sending a you know rejection email
right so pretty impersonal this way
but also think about calendar invites
goldberger for so
for us it was like a perfect example of
a process that could be captured
in a beautiful tool right so automation
meaning bulk emailing candidates
scheduling you know send them a calendar
invite link so they can schedule your
calendar directly so you don't have to
go back and forth make it very friendly
for the applicants
um triggers in the pipeline just like
you see in in sales crms often you know
like
if i drag someone here i want to invite
my colleague to leave a review or i want
to send the email
or send a link to the candidate send an
invite
to us this kind of became normal because
we used to you know
work in techy tools that for us has been
the way to collaborate all along
but we just see a massive trend going on
where companies are like oh my god i'm
doing this manual
in excel sheets you know an outlook and
a folder and i was like
this can save you tons of time you know
that makes a lot of sense and so you're
you know the also that that look on the
market that you're that you're
approaching here
you know it makes a ton of sense now
talk
take me back to the very first people
that you showed this to the very first
customers now you have over 4000 but
does it all begin well to be honest we
were a bootstrap company so
from the company jr we had we started
procurity it was literally a site
project in the beginning because we were
doing campaigns for companies so we
couldn't
afford to spend full time on this it was
a sign project we didn't have any money
so we literally
started to to just call potential
customers before even building it like
hey
we want to build a recruitment tool help
you save time do you want to help out
turns out recruiters are very difficult
people to sell to if you do cold calling
right because they get called
all the time so truth to be told the
first things was
you know first we heard no a thousand
times right then there was a yes then
there was a maybe another yes so
literally first we showed designs we got
people enthusiastic to help out we said
hey we're entrepreneurs we want to just
start get some feedback
i think the first people joining you
know actually joined to help
out and just wanted to help you know
founders do you know get some feedback
rather than actually to itself but at
least things started to get rolling and
we got referrals
and and it got bigger and bigger yeah
and so did anything surprise you you
know along the way as you're
you know building this company you're
you're hiring your own people
what what what surprises came along the
way as you're building recruiting
um to be honest i think the main
surprise to us was
how how much help you can get from your
team
right like we literally you know started
to build the company from the two of us
to the first hires which is the most
scary thing to 10 20 people we now have
about 130 people in multiple countries
but that's this tipping point of around
i think it was around 40 50 people you
know in team size
that we started to let go and get some
head of departments in
they started to do their own hiring and
you have to
as a first-time founder kind of like
trust people to do well and then of
course
incentify them and help them to do well
but it just surprised me that if you
if you really give the responsibility
and trust to people how collaborative
the process could become
right it it literally they started to
the best sales people started to refer
other people and this just became great
hires at the end so
i think the collaboration part was the
thing that surprised us and we figured
well this should be
a company wide effort you know not just
for the recruitment team yeah
right so you were you know we're
touching also a little bit on on the
culture
how intentional were you about you know
building a sustainable culture within
recruiting how did it evolve you know as
you're growing from one person
to dozens of people with thousands of
clients how does the culture
change in your eyes to be honest with us
about culture what is about product what
is about the company in general we never
really had
a fixed northern star you know i've
studied business school so i know it's
it's common to actually write a business
plan and tell everyone this is where
we're going in five years time
it's kind of like this pyramid you know
you work towards your goal but
the truth is it's been pretty opposite
in recruiting it's been like a pyramid
upside down we always said like
what what people do we have what could
we do and we look left and right on
arcade what opportunities out there we
should jump upon okay
ver improvise very much just like we
pivoted from jia run into into
recruiting actually
so the culture has been kind of like
growing growing and
amsterdam is a pretty diverse place to
hire so quite early on
when we had 10 people in the team there
were already eight different cultures
english has been a default language so
you don't like get smaller groups in the
team so
it became very open-minded very
respectful to each other
and to be honest this has never been
something that we said like this is what
we need to build and have a five-year
horizon
it's been pretty improvising on the go
and self-growing organism i guess yeah
it sounds like it i mean now one of the
things that i'm especially curious about
you know with so many people that are
using your product on on a regular basis
with a lot of people working with you
you have to
make some difficult decisions on
priorities right you're now you're like
you started like with it with a small
raft and now you're
you know you're guiding this whole big
ship and you have to make some
big visionary decisions on where to
prioritize where does the company look
how do you go even about assessing these
possibilities and assessing these
decisions
around you and how how does it actually
happen
when you have data points from so many
different clients and
so many perhaps even conflicting ideas
how do you even go about making that
process yeah
to be honest when we started recruiting
we wrote down the ten commandments of an
ideal scalable business this is what we
literally called it so we said
you know we want to have a sales service
pro if you want to be product-led growth
we want to have clients in multiple
countries have a very low barrier to
adopt the software so have a free trial
so people can just trial it if they like
it they sign up with a credit card if
not
no hard feelings so so we literally had
like
like a blueprint of this is the ideal
company we wanted to have
we took all our learnings from the
previous company we said like yo this is
the kind of the model we need to hold on
to
and and it's been very much about
product product
product let's just build the product we
love and spend a lot of time on on
the details right honestly even if we're
thinking about revenue revenue revenue
we just wanted to build the best product
out there and still
is you know in all the way up our
priority
um and and and that's actually easy to
make decisions once it becomes more
complicated or when the company is
getting bigger we literally go back to
that core and say like hey
is this part of our core principles
remember those those commandments or
principles
you know is this product first is this
enhancing
all our customers or are we now
considering building something that just
benefits a few customers
we've been always thinking about the
full group of of customers
and not just follow the money in case
you know someone says i'll pay more if
you build these in these features
that's not what's driving us it's
driving us to to build something that
can be used by as many
companies as possible right right and so
and now a little bit you know higher
level about talent space and recruiting
space
if we're looking you know at this idea
that you know
like 70 or 80 percent of our jobs are
going to be
changed over the next 10 20 years or so
i don't even know what the most
up-to-date approximation is however
inaccurate they may be
how how does recruiting play a part in
this and understanding
the modern workforce which changes quite
frequently you know i know specifically
in tech i don't know in many other
industries but i'm sure that
you know the trend is to have multiple
careers in your life to be okay with
changing
jobs and positions so recruiting you
know is different in its essence you're
not recruiting somebody for 10 years
you're maybe recruiting somebody for two
years
what do you where do you see this whole
industry moving as the years go by
interesting interesting like we came
across some terms that were to be honest
we were pretty new to this whole
industry when we started right we
started our own frustration but it's not
like we carry 20 years of experience on
the recruitment industry
but we're learning a lot and we we like
something like passive candidates that's
never was never on the radar but
apparently you know passive candidates
as in you know you can trigger someone
to follow your company
you know to kind of build a relationship
and maybe one day they actually consider
applying to one of your jobs but passive
candidates as in targeted facebook ads
or linkedin ads you know it's a very
effective way to build a relationship
and this fits within the theme of
employer branding you know thinking
about what's it like to work for me
having proper
videos or pictures on your website you
know but what is it to be a
you know as an employer brand as an
employer right
but we see more companies creating ways
to follow that company to show you this
is us be very transparent
meaning this relationship starts long
before they actually consider applying
it's almost like a sales process where
you engage with your your
leads before they consider becoming a
customer i think that that process
including all the marketing you know
funnels how many visitors how many
conversion rates can be very much
applied to the recruitment process if
you think about it it's literally also a
funnel if you look in our product it
literally is a funnel
and now the kind of step before it's
like who are interested
before they applied right it's it's
super interesting to think about these
dynamics in terms of marketing
100 perry i have a few fun
questions i have many more professional
questions i have a few fun questions i
want to ask you if you're ready for them
go
go yes sure all right we'll start off
easy we'll get a little bit weirder
along the way
what is a favorite subject of yours from
middle school or high school uh it
sounds a bit boring but i've been a big
fan of
math i really like math like
i'm i'm bad at language like even my
dutch was pretty poor to be honest
the writing part but math i'm
comfortable with yeah
i love it um somebody who's a role model
for you or somebody that inspires you
not sure is the best example because a
little bit mixed feeling but
tiger woods has been like a big role
model for me i mean
aside from his personal life i mean to
get back in the game
at like a pretty you know uncommon age
and then
you know with all the injuries he had
and then win the masters again
if you look at that physically being
almost close to impossible with all the
young guys that are like much stronger
and more fit than he is
and then winning the muscles again on on
mental strength that to me is like big
aspect so
really look up the elegance
as if there's no sweat at all i think
i'd say
i mean all these 25 year olds are like
what's happening you know like
it's it's pretty incredible to see the
strength of of mental power
um and just pure brightness
and intelligence somebody who's coming
thinking critically
understanding the opponents
understanding what
you know how this game is operated and
not in you know not looking at every
point
but looking at the at the war in general
and
the higher scope of of the of the field
i think that's just a
you know that that's a pretty good
lesson for entrepreneurship as well i
think and you know
we started talking about golf and we're
finishing here yeah
[Laughter]
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
it but it's a little bit back like a
previous question on a role model but i
think
certain commitments like we always been
very committed to what we do
it can also be negative to commit it
right you could be a bit egocentric
that's the negative side of being
committed but commitment for us is super
important
logic being logic being irrational down
to earth that's very important for us
speeding our culture as well
dots are very direct and logic you could
say and
authenticity is is important like be
yourself and
that just means the people you hire the
people you surround yourself i think if
you're authentic
then you also kind of like get back what
you you know kind of give here so that
that's been important also in a hiring
process we
also screen people on on this example
like you know what's the scenario
that you felt you could not be yourself
right and watch out for those yeah
right i love it perry thank you so so
much for joining me this was
wonderful i really appreciate it and
best of luck with recruiting i don't
think it's luck anymore
i'm pretty sure it looks phenomenal
but thank you very much for taking the
time to join me here and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
michael likewise
thank you take care bye-bye